Hello Tonguç akademi'den hepinize
Merhaba arkadaşlar bugünkü konumuz dı
Family hemen hazırsak başlıyoruz aile
üyelerinde bütün erkeklerde der artikeli
kullanıyoruz çok hızlı konuya giriş
yaptım değil mi Çünkü aslında çok basit
bir konu Sadece burada gördüğümüz
kelimeleri birazcık ezberlememiz
gerekiyor aile üyelerinde bütün
erkeklerde der artikeli kadınlarda ise
diar dikenine kullanıyoruz hemen gelelim
kelimelerimize değer Fatiha Baba değer
gross'a büyük baba ya da bizim
deyimimizde dede şeklinde d 10 kel ancak
ya da dayı anlamına geliyor değer burada
erkek kardeş ya da abi şeklinde
kullanıyoruz biraz zor erkek çocuk değer
eş anlamına geliyor nereden anlıyorum
erkek olduğunu sonundaki
Kız kuzen dinle işte kız yeğen bir en
kelin ise kız torun bilsem süper olur
köşemde 4 tane kelimem var mama Papa opa
Oma Peki bu kelimeleri ben ne için
kullanıyorum neyin karşılığında
kullanıyorum mama
Muta yerine mama diye biliyorum tabii ki
bu kelimeleri Aslında daha çok çocuklar
kullanıyor Yani çocuklar annesine Muta
demiyor da Mama diyor ya da babasına
Papa diyor peki o para grosser yerine
ben opak kısaltılmış halini
kullanabilirim grossmut'a ise Oma
şeklinde kısaltarak kullanabilirim Tabii
ki Sadece çocuklar kullanmıyor Bunu biz
de kullanabiliriz Hatta bunları
kullanmamız aklımıza daha kalıcı hale
getirebilir o ma ma ma ma Papa Son sürat
devam ediyoruz Peki Bütün aile
üyelerimizi öğrendik bunları bir başlık
altında yani üst bir başlık altında
toplamamız gerekiyor bir elten
kimler dahil bu ebeveyn içine
anne ve baba dahil Yani bizim çekirdek
ailemiz der Fatih
Muta diggross anten büyük aile Türkçe'de
Tabii ki bu şekilde Pek kullanımı yok
büyük aile demiyoruz daha çok akrabalar
içerisine giriyor anneannemiz
babaannemiz dedemiz
degrosfata büyükbaba neydi kısaltılmışı
Hopa Liga
kısaltılmışıyla Oma yani anneanne Ya da
babaanne bir girişi değer bunu da dişi
Vesta erkek kardeş kız kardeş Ne
yapıyorum ben bu iki kelimeyi tek bir
başlık altında topluyorum di yaşı Vesta
Kardeşler bir kişi Vesta
biraz zor erkek çocuk bir tahta kız
çocuk Peki ben hangi başka altında
topluyorum
dikenda çocuklar yani her iki Cinsiyette
de
bir başlık altında topluyorum 4 tane
bilmem gereken üst başlık var diye
entendigroos eltendige on the kind the
Son sürat devam ediyoruz aile üyelerini
tanıtırken bilmemiz gereken bir fiil var
Nedir bu fiil
heistendirmek olarak kullanıyoruz Hemen
geliyorum çekimine hyson fiil Aslında
Düzenli bir fiil fakat düzenli derken
bazı yerlerinde bir harf eksikliği
olabilir ya da harf eklemek gerekebilir
bazı düzenli fiillerde Biz bunu
göreceğiz Peki eş Her neyse benim adım
şimdi fiili çekimlerken 6 kişi zamirine
göre değil illa ezberlememiz mi
gerekiyor Aslında mantığını
anladığınızda pek ezber yapmaya gerek
yok nedir mantığı
Bu benim mastar haldeki fiilim adı olmak
kaysın ben fiilimin sonundaki en
takısını Hemen atıyorum yok ediyorum ve
kök halinde bırakıyorum hays peki peki
geldim buraya düzenli fiillerde hemen
bilgilerimizi bir yoklayalım düzenli
fiillerde yaptığımız kullandığımız bir
kural vardı esenten kuralı kökümüzün
yanına gelen yani sonuna eklediğimiz
bazı ekler vardı Neydi bu ekler iş E
getiriyorduk ben kişi zamirinde e
getiriyorduk bakın Köküm
sonunu e takısı getirdim ve fiilimi
çekimlemiş oldum iş her neyse
duaist işte e hemen şuraya ekliyorum
doğuda ise ST takısı Eğer
takısı veya Biz kişi zamirinde çoğulda
aynı şekilde bırakıyorum yani fiilimi
mastar haliyle bırakıyorum Via yine
takısı getiriyorum ze ve ziği de yine
mastar halde bırakıyorum
Peki benim dikkat etmem gereken noktalar
neresi iyiye kişi zamiri do kişi zamiri
ve LGS kişi zamiri Peki geldim ikinci
tekil şahısıma du Benim normalde st2
getirmem gerekiyor ama burada TV şurada
gördüğüm garip harfin arasına bir s
harfi getirmedim Neden Garip harf
diyorum Çünkü gerçekten garip bir harf
ve uzun kuyruğu var yani ben bunu uzun
kuyruklu B diyorum ve bunu Biz 2 S
olarak kullanıyoruz doğuda ST ekinin
geldiğini biliyorum ama benim burada
tekrardan bir s harfi eklememe gerek yok
çünkü 3 bir seye ihtiyacım yok
duaist Ersin
telaffuz ederken sanki 3 tekil şahısta
bir s harfi varmış gibi dur Sadece bu
harfimden kaynaklanıyor O yüzden üçüncü
tekil şahısımda sadece T takısı
ekliyorum Via
bakın Hatta şuradan farklı bir renk
kalem alayım heist iyi High dediğimde
çekimine dikkat edin ve eğer
does Aslında 3 kişi zamirde de
çekimlerim aynı yani ben bu mantığı
anladıktan sonra 6 kişi zamirine göre de
oturup dakikalarca ezber yapmama gerek
yok hemen sağ tarafa geliyorum
örneklerime Daha sonra geçeceğim pose
see Pro noman
çoğullarda iyelik zamirlere neydi benim
Çoğu kişi zamirlerim Via Biz İyi siz
S'si küçük olan zihin onlar ve S'si
büyük olan ziyi Siz anlamına geliyordu
Ve ben buna kibarzi adını veriyorum
kibarzi büyük Peki iyelik zamirlerinde
benim senin onun bizim şeklinde
kullandığımız zamirlerde çoğullarda
nasıl kullanıyoruz der ve ders artikeli
için Via
gunzaia Oya
Ziya
kullanıyor ama ikisinin arasında bir
fark var Yukarıdaki onlar anlamına gelen
zide iradeyken iyisini küçük yazıyorum
baş harfini buradaki S'si büyük yani
kibarzi ile ise iyi ya derken ı olarak
yazıyorum Yani aynı buradaki s harfi
gibi baş harfini büyük yazıyorum diye
artık eline geldim viya'da 10 üzeri iyi
oyna
ve kibarzi ile ise yine ire iyelik
zamirini kullanıyorum geldim örneklerime
Ve bu Kim diyelim ki aile üyelerimizden
birini tanıtıyoruz bir arkadaşımıza
tanıtıyoruz ve Bize soruyor veya esas bu
kim ne diyeceğim hemen burada bir ipucum
var tente renkli tente teyze ya da hala
anlamına geliyordu Ve artikeli Didi ders
is Benim teyzem ya da benim halam demek
istiyorum
dersi
[Müzik]
Bu benim teyzem bu benim halam Peki We
hele Muta hemen bilgilerimi yokluyorum
tekillerde iş için Mynet Doğu için dyned
yani sen senin iş Ben benim şeklinde Ne
sormuş bana soruda bir hays dyne muhtaç
senin annenin ismi nedir bakın ikinci
pozisyonumda fiilim var ve çekimi neye
göre olmuş daha yine Muta yani Muta
şurada gördüm üçüncü tekil şahısa göre
çekimimi yapıyorum bir hastane Muta Ne
diyeceğim Benim annemin adı diyeceğim
Mynet
Olga Benim annemin adı Olga Peki veya
estas ipucuma bakıyorum opa yani benden
Dedemi tanıtmamı istiyor Nasıl
başlayacağım cümleye veya estast hemen
şöyle cümlenin sonundan başına doğru
gidiyorum ders
istopa değer opa benim demek istiyorum
erkeklerden mind kullanıyorum Benim
dedem ders
burada senin erkek kardeşinin ya da
Abinin ismi nedir Ne diyeceğim daha ne
demiş Senin demiş Benim de main demem
lazım
[Müzik]
Ali benim erkek kardeşimin adı Ali peki
diyelim ki Karşımda bir arkadaşım var ve
yanında dedesi var yanımdaki arkadaşım
ise Bana karşımdaki arkadaşımın Dedesini
soruyor veya istat Ve karşımdaki
arkadaşımda erkek benim hangi iyelik
zamirini kullanmam gerekiyor
Yani onun derken onun dedesi bu onun
dedesi diyeceğim ders
İsrail Oppa bu onun dedesi
İsrail Opera bu onun dedesi hemen Son
sürat devam ediyoruz ve bilsem süper
olur köşemizde devam edelim nesnenin
kime ait olduğunu söylemek için yeni
tiffs yani Es takısı ismin in halini ya
da fon kelimesi kullanılır Az önce
dediğim gibi ders is Ne dedik hemen
şuraya ekley
bu onun dedesi Peki ben burada şurada
cümlemin sonunda isim de kullanabilirim
diyelim ki Tuna'nın dedesi diyeceğim
Nasıl söylerim Tuna
'nın dedesi Peki hemen üste geliyorum Bu
cümlemde benim nasıl bir anlam varmış
ninninin anlamı varmış Yani ben Es
takısını ya da fon kelimesini
kullandığımda cümlemde onun dedesi Onun
babası onun teyzesi şeklinde
kullanıyorum
Eylül'ün kız kardeşi
Ece'nin annesi Peki Dikkat etmem gereken
nokta neresi fon isimden önce geliyor
yani
Ece Eylül Ayşe gibi özel isimlerden önce
Es takısı ise hemen sonra isimden sonra
geliyor hemen aşağı bakıyorum bir o fon
Ece'nin büyük annesi Ben bunu hangi
şekilde de yazabilirim
büyükannesi Bakın iki farklı şekilde de
ne yapıyorum buradaki tatlı şamayı
tanıta biliyorum ders Auto fontay
yayın arabası Ya da nasıl kullanabilirim
Tuncay Auto Peki ne yaptık fon isimden
hemen önce geliyor Es takısı ise isimden
hemen sonra yani bitişik halde yazıyoruz
Peki veya estas Bu kim diyeceğim ki bu
benim anneannem ders
inye
Oma Neden muayene kullandım çünkü diama
bütün kadın aile üyelerinde hangi
artikeli getiriyorduk diye artikelini
getiriyorduk bir heiste
3 tekil şahıs yani o diyorum onun ismi
nedir Ne yapacağım Özlem'e başı alacağım
zil hey
Olga Hep de bu isim aklıma geliyor Zee
He Hee Olga onun ismi Olga kim olduğunu
söyledim ismini söyledim ve yaşını
sormak istiyorum iyice tanımak istiyorum
wealt is zi ne yapacağım cümle mi Şöyle
sona doğru yani başa doğru hemen buradan
alacağım zi Is fön şey Yarın al
Ozi dediğim kimden bahsediyorum omadan
bahsediyorum 3 tekil şahıs o 50 yaşında
Yani ben ailemi tanıtırken ya da bir
başkasının yanındaki birini tanıtırken
fon genitive ismin halinden
yararlanabilirim Evet aile üyelerimizi
de tanıttığımıza göre ne yapıyoruz Son
sürat devam ediyoruz haben sahip olmak
aile üyelerimizi tanıtırken sahip olmak
ya da var anlamına gelen harbın filmi
kullanıyoruz ve aynı İngilizce'deki have
fiiline benzetebiliriz aile tanıtırken
Ailemizde kimler olduğunu söylemek
istediğimizde haben sahip olmak fiilini
kullanıyoruz harven fiili genellikle
akuzatif ile kullanılıyor nedir bu
öküzatif ismin i hali şimdi
örneklerimize daha iyi anlayacağız
gelelim fiilimizin çekimine ne
yapıyorduk düzenli fiillerde esenten
kuralına uyguluyorduk habbın fiilinde de
evet kısmen uyguluyoruz fakat bazı kişi
zamirlerinde şekil değişikliği olmuyor
değil iş habe Du Hast ezi Ez
ve zihâben şeklinde çekimliyoruz Peki
geldim akuzatif örneklerime Birazdan
geçeceğim akübetif yani ismin i halinde
Ben neyi belirtmek istiyorum belirtme
durumunu Yani birini kastediyorum mesela
Elimde bir kalem var tek kelime
söylediğimde kalem Ama ben bu kalemi
belirtmek girdiğimde kalemi diyorum yani
ismin i halini kullanıyorum Peki hemen
gelelim örneklerimize has to Aynen
burada
derken artık elim neydi der artikeli
hemen şuradan geliyorum nominatif Yalın
hal
akuzatif ismin i hali Ben nominatiften
akuatife çevirmek istediğimde artık
Ellerime çok dikkat etmem gerekiyor
Yalın haldeki artikellerim nedir değer
için aynı kullanıyorum diye için aynı
ders için yine aynı kullanıyorum ama
ismin iyi halini kullanmak istiyorum
yani Kozmetik halini kullanmak istiyorum
dikkat edin der dene dönüşüyor ve aynı
Aynen şeklinde bir değişime uğruyor diye
aynı şekilde kalıyor daha yine aynı
şekilde kalıyor yani belirli artı kelime
değil tekrardan O kızatifte değil Ders
Ders belirsiz ayeti kerimede ise aynı
tekrardan akuzatifte aynı şekilde
kullanıyorum yani Dikkat etmem gereken
nokta sadece der artikeli hastau Aynen
buruğu da senin bir erkek kardeşin var
mı Yani bir erkek kardeşe sahip misin
Değer ne dedik Yukarıda hemen bakalım
hawın fiilimiz genellikle akuzatif ile
kullanılıyor Yani şunu aklınızdan
çıkarmayın hain artı aküzatif hasta
Aylin bunu da değer burada bakın ne
yaptım Aynen bir derken nominatif yani
Yalın haldeki gibi kullanmıyorum
akuzatif haliyle kullanıyorum senin bir
erkek kardeşin var mı önce ne yapacağım
olumlu bir cümle kuracağım Evet benim
bir erkek kardeşim var Ben bir erkek
kardeşe sahibim şu kalemin rengini hemen
birazcık değiştirelim
renkli renkli Olsun ya iş haber
Aynen burada benim bir erkek kardeşim
var Ben bir erkek kardeşe sahibim ne
yapıyorum artı kelime dikkat ediyorum
Peki cümleyi olumsuz yapacağım olumsuz
dediğimizde bazen böyle nasıl yapacağım
olumsuz nasıl yapılır işte Line'dan
sonra ne gelir şundan sonra ne gelir
diye kafamızın karışmasına hiçbir
şekilde gerek yok Tek yapmamız gereken
üstteki olumlu cümlemizin aynısını yapıp
ufak bir Püf nokta ekleyeceğiz Hemen
yazalım nine
[Müzik]
şimdi cümlemin başı olumsuz nine Hayır
demişim ama cümlemin devamı Olumlu
gidiyor hemen cümlemi olumsuza çevirmek
istiyorum Ne yapacağım belirsiz artık
kelime olan Aynen artı kelime boşuna hop
bir K ekliyorum ve işlem tamam nine
kardeşim yok Ben bir kardeşe sahip
değilim Peki şu Vesta ipucumda ne demiş
bana kız kardeşim yani demem gerekiyor
ki Abim filmini kullanmam gerekiyor
benim bir kız kardeşim var kız kardeş
için artikel ne kullanıyorduk değil o
zaman iş habere çekimimizi kontrol
ediyoruz iş abi aynı swester Çünkü neden
akuzatifte olsa nominatif de olsa diye
artikel için her zaman aynı belirsiz
artık eline kullanıyorum iş abi aynı
sweste o para demiş buradaki zihimiz kim
3 tekil yani o anlamına gelen zi
diyeceğim ki onun bir dedesi var zihi
için çekim nasıl hat getiriyorum ze had
I'm Oppa neden aynı Çünkü der artık Elif
Peki ben buraya bir şaşırtmaçlı bir
cümle yazdım hemen hatayı bulduğunuzu
biliyorum Benim buraya ne yazmam lazım
ben ha bunu neyle kullanıyorum
akuzatifle yani ismin i haliyle
kullanıyorum o zaman ben nominatif
haliyle yani Yalın haliyle yazamam ne
eklemem gerekiyor Eğer için dene
dönüştürmem gerekiyor ve belirsiz
artikel kullanırken ise Aynen kullanmam
gerekiyor Yani Cihat Aynen o part der o
pa Aynen o pa Evet Son sürat devam
ediyoruz ailemizi ve aile üyelerimizi
tanıtırken Şimdi üst başlıklardan
bahsetmiştik flural çoğul sizinle teki
üst başlıklarımızda kimler vardı de
Gross elten büyük ailemiz yani içerisine
dedemiz anneannemiz babaannemiz giriyor
dielten ebeveynlerimiz dikaş Vista
Kardeşler dikin da çocuklar different'in
ise akrabalar Şimdi burada gördüğüm tüm
üst başlıklar ne çoğul içerisinde birden
fazla aile üyesi barındırıyor Peki zingu
Family yazmışım aile anlamına geliyor
Neden tekil içerisinde bu çok kafa
karıştırsa da direkt şu mantıkla
düşünürseniz hiç Kafanız karışmayacak
değil familye bir tane ailemiz var
içerisinde kaç kişi olursa olsun sadece
bir aileye sahip olduğumuz için biz
diffamilya kelimesine tekil olarak
düşünmeliyiz peki posasif pronoun Yani
iyelik zamirlerinden benim derken ne
kullanıyorum
muayenede ise diye artikelini
kullanıyorum hemen şu çoğul üst
başlıklar ve tekil üst başlık olan
difamily örneğimizde inceleyelim çoğul
olarak da sizin muayene elter bakın Zain
fiilinin yani olmak fiilinin çoğulunu
kullanıyorum Neden Çünkü en ten kelimem
benim çoğul içerisinde anne ve baba var
Ben sizin mind Fata un My Name Muta Eğer
çoğul bir cümle kuracaksam Ben Zain
fiilinin zint olarak çekimini
kullanıyorum Peki tekil kullanacağım
Yani ailemi tanıtacağım ders
esamilya Bu benim ailem ne yaptım Zain
fiilinin tekil çekimini kullandım Çünkü
ne demiştik difamily'ye bir tane ailemiz
var içerisinde ne kadar aile üyesi
olursa olsun
Eğer Nikola şurada Das İsmail Fatiha da
diyebilirdik
değil mi
Das is my ne Muta her şekilde de
kullanabilirim Dikkat etmem gereken
nokta ne kelimenin artı kelime göre
gelen iyelik zamirim der için mind diye
için Mine hemen bilsem süper olur köşeme
geliyorum ne görüyorum burada Bunu da
değer burada erkek kardeş Ama belki
benim birden fazla erkek kardeşim var O
zaman benim kelimemi çoğul hale getirmem
lazım Buraya da Kent kenda çocuk
çocuklar tahta taşta kız çocuk kız evlat
ve kız çocuklar ya da kız evlatlar
diyebiliriz Yani benim birden fazla kız
çocuğum var mesela schwess'da kız kardeş
Kız Kardeşler ya da ablalar zor erkek
çocuk
erkek çocuklar ne yapıyorum
kelimelerimi tekil olan kelimelerime
çoğullaştırıyorum ama belirli bir kural
olmadığı için kelimeyi öğrendiğinizde
çoğul halinde öğrenin iş habe Aynen
burada benim bir erkek kardeşim var ya
da abim var ama benim birden fazla erkek
kardeşim var ya da iki tane erkek
kardeşim var Ne demem ne yapmam
gerekiyor hemen sayı belirtmem gerekiyor
cümlemin içerisinde ve kelimemi çoğul
yapmam gerekiyor Ey
Habibe Benim iki kardeşim var Ben iki
erkek kardeşe sahibim ders
Bu benim çocuğum da
Bunlar benim çocuklarım kinda çoğul
İnşallah benim bir kız işim var ya da
benim bir ablam var ama Birden fazla var
İki tane var 3 tane var Ne diyeceğim iş
haber
tekil kelime mi çoğul hale getiriyorum
ve öncesinde de bir sayı belirtiyorum
unutmamamız gereken nokta neresiydi
difamilya kelimesini yani aile
kelimesini her zaman tekil olarak
kullanıyoruz Evet o zaman hazırsak
ödüllü sorumuza geçiyoruz ödüllü
sorumuzda hasta aynı tente tente ne
demektir teyze ya da hala ne soruyorum
soruda senin bir teyzen ya da bir halan
var mı cevaplarınızı yorumlara
bekliyorum Bir sonraki dersimizde
görüşmek üzere hoşça kalın
[Müzik]
[Alkış]